قد يكون الشتاء العدو الاقصى لاوكرانيا
وقد لا يكون انها مساله يجزم بها هذه
المره من يحسب خطوته مليا متداركا ما
سيجلبه فصل الثلوج بكل ابعد. اذا المحللون
عسكريون قالوا ان الشتاء قد يغير مسار حرب
باكملها لماذا باختصار ان الابعاد
اللوجسيا لوجستيه منسيه اذا احيانا رغم ان
الحركه الجغرافيه لا تبعد عن كونها قدرا
يجبر اي من الاطراف المتحاربه على تغيير
الخطه بعد ان يفوت الاول هذا يعيدنا الى
القوه العسكريه ف رغم الامكانيه والاعداد
سيقف الجنود مكتوفي الايدي باسلحتهم الضخم
امام ماتقلبات الطقس الذي يصعب قتال
المشات والمدرعات ناهي كانه يعقد عمليات
الدم
اذا تكتيكات الرئيس
شبه واضحه للعين فبعد الانسحاب الروسي من
غرب خرسون وعبور ضفه نحو الشرق والتراجع
العسكري
ان تصب جهدها باي طريقه لضرب عزيمه
الاوكرانيين واغراقهم بظلام دامس وبردا
قارس خطوه يراها حلف شمال الاطلسي محاوله
روسيه لاستخدام الشتاء كالسلاح حرب ضد
الاوكرانيين وعليه اجتمع الحلفاء في
رومانيا
تشمل الوقود والامدادات الطبيه لتجبر تلك
ضربات روسيه شركات اوكرانيه الكهرباء على
تقنين امداداتها بواقع 60 بالمئه في كاف
لتبقى النسبه المتبقيه وحدها من تصارع
تربيه احتياجات البنيه التحتيه الاساسيه
للاستهلاك اليومي وامام سقيع الشتاء حيث
الوجه يجدد الرئيس الاوكراني فولو دي
ميرسيلينسكي دعوه شعبه للتكاتف معنا
لتجاوز الازمه علما ان اسبوعا وحشيا اخر
ينتظرهم على حدث تعبيرهم
جديده نحن نعرف هذا على وجه الدقه وطالما
كانت لديهم صواريخ فلن يهداوا للاسف لكن
قدرتنا على مساعده بعضنا البعض والاعتناء
بمنهم في اصعب الاوضاع كبار السن والاسر
التي لديها اطفال ومن فقدوا منازلهم
واقاربهم بسبب الحرب مساعدتنا المتبادله
هي احد عناصر الحمايه من الارهاب وهي مصدر
قوتنا
وباستهدافي روسيا قلبنا التحتيه وقتل
المدنيين بردا يريد بوتن ان يصنعه وطن
عميقه بين الحكومه الاوكرانيه وشعبها
ليضغط على السلطه ثم تلجا للدبلوماسيه
خاضعه لمطالب الاوكرانيا لكن المؤرخين
التاريخيين يرون ان ذلك لم يجدي نفعا
مستذكرين ما جرى في الحرب العالميه
الثانيه حينما اعتمد الغرب على القذف
الاستراتيجي سواء مع اليابان او المانيا
فكلهما كان رد شعبه بالالتفاف حول السلطات
اجمالا يسعد بوتن وجنوده بتحقيق مكسب اخر
على اجابه الشرقيه لا سيما الدم باس وايضا
يوازن الرئيس الرودادا فعل الغربي ويقيس
صبرهم اما ميدانيا فان اجواء الشتاء حينما
تقلب المشهد للابيض ليس بالضروره ان توقف
الحرب لان الارض تبقى صالحه لسير الاليات
حتى فوق الثلج والجليده لكنهم مقيادون
بالطرقات المعبده وهذا امر يجعلها هدفا
سهلا خاصه مع التكنولوجيا الجديده
المستعمله
بكره يعني اما يعني بان تجاوز الساقيه
بالنسبه للجنود مقدورون عليه بالمساعدات
والحزام الشتوي لكن الحبكه الحقيقيه
للمعركه الاكثر تعقيدا لم تبدا بعد ولن
تكون اساسا في هذا الطقس مرحله ما بعد
الشتاء هي الاقصى والاصعب بلا شك فتجاوز
الثلوج بالمدرعات حتما اسهل من ذوبان كل
تلك البحيرات المتجمده فالذوبان والوحل
الذي يتشكل بسببه هو اكبر عائق لتقدم
الجيوش خاصه في حاله المناوره والهجوم وما
بينهما يعزز الوحل استخدام المدافع لكن
الهدف الروسي باسترداد كل اراضي الاقاليم
الاربعه سيجعلها تختار الهجوم واذا كنتم
تذكرون تلك القريه التي اختارت ان تغرق
نفسها مقابل الا يدخل عدوها على ارضها
متجهها النحو العاصمه كاف وفعلا نجحت
حينها دامي داف باعاقه القوات الروسيه
فيضان متعمد يجبرها على التحول نحو تضاريس
اصعب لذا يريد الرئيس بوتن كسب الوقت الان
حتى ولو على حساب استنزافي صواريخ الذكيه
فقط لتحضير القوى العسكريه واعاده تعبئه
مخازن وذلك تحذيرا لمرحلتي ما بعد الشتاء
وما بين اول الربيع واخره قد يكون هذا
الفصل المزهر اشد الامامه
ندفع ثمن باهظا لهذا الانتصار لكن يجب الا
نتراجع وان يحاول حتى النهايه
لا كهرباء ولا تدفئه في نوفمبر اعيش في
شقه في منزل قديم من طابقين يشغلون
التدفئه ليلا عندما تكون هناك كهرباء وهي
متوفره لمده اربع ساعات في اليوم